We're here with Jane Krakowski,
the amazing host of "Name That Tune."
As well as, oh my God, a lifetime, a resume,
a CV of the angels and gods.
I mean, how long-
How European of you, a CV?
Right?
I know.
I love that!
And it's like Latin and I can't even say what it means.
I just know it means resume in Latin.
(Jane laughing)
(audience laughing)
Like, what's your CV, you know?
I didn't learn that until like, really late in life
that a CV was also a resume
'cause it's such a European term, is it?
Isn't it?
All I know is I think it's Latin?
All right.
For resume.
For CV (stammering).
God, see, there you go.
(audience applauding)
Well, "Name That Tune" is such an iconic institution.
Yeah.
I did some research.
It started as a radio show in the 50s, 1952.
And then became a franchised television show in the 70s.
And now with your esteemed iteration that launched in 2021,
how are you liking it?
I mean, it's such a, it is an institution.
It is, and I, you know,
when I heard it was being rebooted,
I loved the show from my childhood,
which I guess would be the 70s iteration going into the 80s.
Right.
Yeah.
Kathy Lee Gifford singing some of the songs.
Who is Kathy Lee Johnson?
Great trivia right there.
That's great trivia, that is exactly right.
And so I just was, I remember, I grew up
in a very musical household and I remember watching
the show in my childhood and all of my family
trying to guess what the tune was
and as few notes as we could, as you do on the show.
And I was always in love with it.
So, when I heard they were rebooting it,
I was like, "I'd love to do that."
I think it's a good match for me and I love music
and I have so much fun hosting this show.
I'm enjoying it so much.
I love Randy Jackson.
I don't know if you know him?
Of course.
He's amazing.
Not personally, but-
(audience applauding)
And I have been watching the show and it is addictive.
You, it doesn't, it doesn't surprise me
that it is a name or an iconic show
that matriculates into wanting to play it in real life.
But you watch the show and you, I can't turn it off.
It's like, I'm like, "I wanna get the next one.
What's the next one gonna be?"
(Jane laughing)
It's so fun, it's so good.
Yeah, I love that.
And I also, I'm just a game person.
I love playing games.
I love going to game nights at friends' houses.
And I feel like I get that invested
with all the contestants that come on too.
I find myself rooting for them
and really hoping that they'll get it.
You know, as host, you have all the,
like here I have all the answers on the card.
So, it's a lot easier for me.
But I feel like what was unexpected of being host was
that I found myself really rooting
for the contestants to win as much money
as they could when they come on.
I totally understand.
And as you're watching it, it is just the best show.
You just play along with it.
You can't get enough.
It really is addictive.
Now, you did "Schmigadoon!"
(audience cheering/applauding)
I love it, I love it.
And I mean, God, there's so many incredible people
in that cast, including Ariana DeBose.
Newly Oscar winner, Ariana DeBose.
(Jane chuckling)
(audience applauding)
Well, it's funny that you mention that
because I actually brought a clip to show you.
Okay.
I mean, Rita Moreno won the Academy Award,
you deserve it too.
Oh.
Period.
(audience applauding/cheering)
Thank you.
Oh my God, I'm gonna cry.
(audience applauding)
Oh my God, I'm really crying, you guys.
This is terrible.
You do, because you put all of that work into it.
Years of effort and a triple threat.
There's so much that you accomplished in this movie.
It is the most firing electric performance
I have seen in my life, let alone in the last several years.
You are a revelation in this movie as "Anita."
(audience cheering/applauding)
That's so beautiful.
What was she like to work with?
Well, so wonderful.
I knew her before then through the Broadway community.
Yes, yes, of course.
I mean, you have been involved with
for as long as, as I know, and that's where she came up.
Right, it's one of my,
it's obviously one of my first loves
and it's why I love doing "Schmigadoon!"
because it sort of brought the world
of musical theater to Apple TV+.
But Ariana is also amazing in "Schmigadoon!"
She's just an electrifying talent and I'm so happy for her.
And we've been texting through her entire-
Really?
Like, award winning run, you know?
The whole lead up, just checking in, like, "How you doing?"
Like, we're all just so proud of her.
I've, "Schmigadoon!" has some really wonderfully
acclaimed people in it but they're also
the nicest cast I've ever worked with.
Everybody is on a group text
and everyone is rooting for the other person.
So entirely supportive and that's rare for a show.
I think it's 'cause we filmed "Schmigadoon!"
during the pandemic.
We all had to quarantine together.
We all, it was very much like the old fashion musical,
where like, "let's get a barn and put on a show,"
it kind of felt like.
Even though it's a major television show.
(upbeat music)